what is your source of hope for the
future of human civilization
well i think it it resides in
[Music]
um
you know some of what you've been saying
which is the in the persistence
of this civilization over time despite
you know the incredible setbacks
you know two enormous world wars you
know the nuclear standoff the
uh
you know the horrible things we're
experiencing now with climate change and
migration and stuff like that
that despite these things
you know we are
persisting
and we are continuing and like you say
we're continuing to invent and we're
continuing to try to solve these
problems
and you know we're continuing to love as
well as hate
and um
you know that um
you know i'm basically i mean i have
children and grandchildren and i think
they're gonna they're gonna be just fine
you know i'm not a i'm not a
a a doom and gloomer you know i'm not a
cassandra saying the world is coming to
an end i'm not like that at all
um
you know i i think that um
you know things will persist another by
the way source of
tremendous optimism on on my part the
kids i teach
you know i i teach some unbelievably
fantastic young people you know who are
sort of like you say they're dreamers
and they're and they're problem solvers
and they're um
[Music]
they're i mean they they have enormously
humane
uh
values and ways of thinking about the
world and they want to they want to do
good
you know if you take the kind of
i mean
this has probably been true all the way
along but i mean the percentage of
do-gooders
you know is really enormously large now
whether they end up working for some
kind of shark law firm or something
or or
you know that that that kind of thing or
whether they end up human rights lawyers
is they all want to be right
you know is a different kind of question
but but certainly um
you know these young people are talented
they're smart they're
wonderful values they're energetic they
work hard you know they're focused
and of course it's not just stanford i
mean it's all over the country you know
you have young people who really want to
contribute
and they want to contribute i mean you i
mean it's true some of them end up you
know
working to get rich i mean that's
inevitable right but um but the
percentages are actually rather small at
least at this age you know maybe when
they get a mortgage and a family and
that sort of thing you know the
financial well-being will be more
important to them but right now
uh you know you catch this young
generation and they're fantastic they're
fantastic and and they're not um
what they're often portrayed as being
you know kind of silly and naive and
knee-jerk leftists and they're not at
all like that um
you know they're really
they're really fine young people so
that's a source of optimism to me too
what advice would you give to those
young people today maybe in high school
in college at stanford maybe to your
grandchildren
about how to uh
have a career they can be proud of have
a life they can be proud of
pursue careers that are in the public
interest you know in one fashion or
another and not just in their interests
um
and and that would be i mean it's not
bad to pursue a career in your own
interests i mean as long as you're
it's something that's useful and
positive for the you know for for
their families or whatever
but yeah so i mean i i try to i try to
advise kids to find themselves somehow
you know find it
who they want to be and what they want
to be and try to pursue it
and the ngo world is growing uh as you
know and uh and a lot of young people
are kind of throwing themselves into it
and and um
you know
[Music]
human rights watch and that kind of
stuff and and you know they want to do
that kind of work and it's uh it's very
admirable
um
i i i tend to think
that even if you're not working in human
rights there's a certain way in which if
you live with integrity
the
i believe that all of us or many of us
have a bunch of moments in our lives
when we're posed with the decision
it's a quiet one maybe it'll never be
written about or talked about
what you get to choose
whether you uh
there's a choice
that
is difficult to make it might require
sacrifice but it's the choice
that uh
the best version of that person would
make
um that's the best way i can sort of say
how to act with integrity it's the very
thing that would resist the early days
in nazi germany it sounds dramatic to
say but
those little actions
and i feel like
the best you can do to avoid genocide
on scale is for all of us to live in
that way
to within those moments unrelated
potentially to human rights to anything
else is to take those actions
like i i believe that all of us know the
right thing to do i know that's right i
think that's right i did you put it very
well i couldn't have done it better
myself
you